major drama on the view today right
before a scheduled studio interview with
vice president kamala harris co-host
sunny hostin
but
i need uh the two of you to step off for
a second okay anna and and uh and we're
going to bring it back
and we'll tell you why more information
later it's a tease we'll tell you why in
a couple of minutes
so shall i introduce the vice president
yes
okay
so vice president
no no okay shall we dance let's do a tap
dance
what happened is that uh sonny and anna
both apparently tested positive for
covey in the meantime until she gets out
here maybe the audience
would like to participate in the show
does it
[Applause]
now it's my time to speak okay co-host
sonny hostin and anna navarro tested
positive for kovid and were forced to
leave the set it delayed the interview
with the vice president for over 30
minutes harris eventually sat down by a
remote but it left little time for the
hard-hitting issues
i've been very clear about the images
that you and i both saw of those law
enforcement officials on horses i i was
outraged by it
i it was horrible and um and
deeply troubling it also evoked images
of some of the worst moments of our
history
where that kind of behavior has been
used against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african americans
during times of slavery
okay uh sandra i want to go to you i
know you've been following the story
closely obviously for
every minute of live um i watched the
whole thing unfold because we were all
tuning in it was ahead of my show um
this afternoon this happened a couple
hours beforehand and this was a you know
she's not giving any other media
availabilities and she's definitely not
delivering press conferences anywhere so
we had to watch to see what she was
going to say most particularly on the
border i'll let you know she finally was
introduced 51 minutes into show and that
was the only thing she said about
problems at the border not the
unprecedented number of migrants flowing
over our southern border not the
horrible inhumane conditions that
thousands of haitian migrants have been
living in under that del rio bridge it
was about those photographs jessica that
was i i'll call it shocking i mean she
could have easily transitioned to
184 days i looked into it before i came
out here this evening 184 days ago she
was in charge of the border and she had
nothing else to say on it i thought was
shocking the other thing cringeworthy
don't know why they did it the way they
did it you know they tested positive
right thing to do is yank them offset
throw it a commercial get them off
they're not sure why they did it the way
that they did they went to awkward
questions from the audience about
marriage advice i don't know um but
testing i don't know why they weren't
tested sooner considering the vice
president was coming on and why they
didn't know before they went to set
yeah jesse that part of it seemed
strange like that there would be a 9 a.m
test if you have the second most
powerful person
in the country coming out to sit next to
your co-host versus something that you
would get back in the middle of the show
well first if you're vaxxed and she's
vast then why are we testing but if abc
has to test why'd they time it like that
they should have gotten tested long
before can i do it greg godfather
imitation please do i borrow your
glasses please oh sure okay oh wow
there's my greg fell invitation okay
the view's been on the air for 20 years
and this was the first breakthrough the
ladies ever had
that's all i got
um but think about how terrible i
thought that was good
that was really good i don't have
writers like you greg i could think of
that myself
i should have worn it on the tip but
think about how bad luck comma is first
she's the borders are right and then
they go to vietnam during afghanistan
and then she comes on the view
and reminds everybody that biden has not
crushed the virus and undermines
confidence in vaccines she's probably
going back to the white house be like
joe you're not going to believe what
happened here judy's got to be thinking
to himself god i should have picked
pocahontas
honestly and the one time she had a
chance to talk she lied
where are the fact checkers
where was the where are the fact
checkers
are they right here i'm one of them uh
the vice president uh is a hoax spreader
the jessie smallette thing she's spread
all around twitter she's never deleted
that tweet she went on the view to
spread this propaganda and this whip
hoax that these agents
were doing things that they were not
doing she smeared their character
indicted them before there's been a
thorough investigation and how dare she
do that when they're just simply doing
the job that she is supposed to be in
charge of and the job that she is
supposed to be doing
she should be at the border not in new
york city
i can't believe you guys didn't like my
godfather
i said it was good greg loved it it was
deeply hurtful
this might be an hr issue yeah yes what
you did to me yeah make it one
i dare you
uh she did cover right she got in the
nine minutes went to a bunch of
different topics she talked about the
borders she talked about what's going on
vaccines she talked about uh abortion
rights
do you think that this suggests that she
owes the ladies another visit or at
least another long-form interview oh yes
because it's going to be so pressing
well it was supposed to be an hour so
yeah i think she was there to find out
the root causes of the views stupidity
that's why she was there good i think my
impression of you
but okay can i just talk about the whole
cover thing that was the most
unnecessary drama ever that was like
that was as choreographed as like the
rose ceremony they everybody knew or
like those before and after scenes and
like home renovation shows everybody
knew what was going on but they had to
build it up and build it up so it was
interesting that actually probably
worked but this is really just a slumber
party in hell uh i don't know honestly i
don't know how
if you took the audience away the
applause so the signals for applause
nobody would know what the hell is going
on in this show it's true it's a it's a
strange universe didn't look at my notes
the entire time did you use those
audience cues on your show no i didn't
you don't use them no actually you did
written down unnecessary
i said yeah no see i wrote it but then
memorized
because it helps my brain fertilize the
thought
you should try that yes i should i need
to fertilize my brain
for that on that very strange crap on
your head
all right you guys stop uh up next
president biden brushing off plunging
poll numbers as americans question his
confidence
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else